shooter grinders are shipped all over
the world up to 80 machines a year of
course each machine is thoroughly tested
before shipping but the testing is
particularly rigorous when the
destination is the united states the
imported machines have to conform to a
dizzying array of u.s standards
the germans have the ce norm the
americans the ul plug standard the
germans have different cable coding
regulations different color codes we
have of course metric threading the
americans use whitworth thread standards
or threads measured in inches every
little detail requires an enormous
amount of work
seven thousand kilometers away in the
u.s state of illinois industrial furnace
maker ibsen faces similar problems
whenever the mid-sized firm ships its
products to europe its engineers have to
deal with a mountain of eu regulations
the europeans require that the grounding
cable and control panels have a 70 30
color separation
the north americans does not require
that and just learning that or
understanding those regulations require
many hours of engineering and research
the firm has a turnover of some 170
million euros a year it could be a lot
more of ibsen didn't have to make
different models for the american and
european markets like many other
companies they hope that a free trade
agreement between the eu and the united
states will mean fewer regulations
another example pwm makes electronic
price signs for petrol stations
a third of its production goes to the
united states
pwm's chief executive officer adds up
the cost of getting his signs certified
for import by the us authorities
vietnam we pay an average of ten
thousand dollars for the initial testing
and that's just to get the product
approved for import
afterwards we have to pay two thousand
dollars every quarter so that they can
make unannounced inspections and verify
that we are really using the officially
approved parts
and any change no matter how small can
cost another two thousand
machine manufacturers on both sides of
the atlantic are tangled in a jungle of
norms codes and regulations
ttip could make trade between the us and
eu a lot easier